We're going to open up our project now and take a look at setting up an IK Rig asset.
We're going to set this up with a quadruped character and show you how you can really
quickly create what you need to start adjusting the pose of your character.
We can even preview inside the IK Rig editor to see how it might affect an animation that's
playing on the character.
And this is our IK Rig editor window.
So on the left hand side here, we have the hierarchy, and this will show us the bones
that we have inside our Skeletal Mesh, as well as any IK goals or IK settings that we've
set up inside this IK Rig.
On the bottom left, there is the solver stack, and this will display any IK solvers that
we're currently using for the Skeletal Mesh.
Then we have the output log along the bottom here, and that displays any errors or warnings
that you might have with your Rig.
And then top right, we have the details panel, and this is just a universal panel that will
display details about anything you currently have selected.
And on the bottom right, we have the asset browser.
Now this will show you a list of animation sequences that you can use to preview the
behavior of your IK Rig, which we'll do in just a moment once we've got it set up.
There are two main things that we need to set up for the full body IK system here.
We need to set the IK goals, and we need to set the solver root.
Now the IK goals are the effective points at the end of your IK chains, and this is
the target that the chain will try to reach by adjusting the pose of your character, and
they work together with the solver to achieve that.
Now since the IK goals are going to be the end points of your bone chains, they'll typically
be set up on the hands and the feet of your characters.
And the second thing is the solver root, which is typically the starting bone in the chain.
This is just so the solver knows which bones it should be adjusting.
And in this case with a full body IK, we're going to use the pelvis.
That's because this is the true root of where the character's movement comes from, rather
than the actual root of the skeleton, and it'll give us much better results.
So the first thing we're going to set is the IK goals.
And to do that, I'm going to select all four feet of our character here.
And if I show our skeleton, we'll be able to see that we have the end joints selected
currently.
And if we right click inside the hierarchy here, we can choose a new IK goal, or we could
press control N for that.
And it's going to ask us what kind of solver we want to use for this.
Now we could use sort of a limb IK for this, which will just set up individual limbs for
each of these controls.
And then we need to set up, you know, individual roots for each of the solvers on sort of the
shoulders and shoulder blades and hips down here.
But because we want to do like a full body system, we're going to choose the full body
IK.
So if we choose add solver, you see that in our solver stack here, we now have a new
solver full body IK.
And it does give us a warning here that it's missing a root bone, which means that although
it knows the end of each joint chain, it doesn't know the beginning.
It doesn't know where it should be starting from.
So if we come up to our pelvis here with our solver selected, I'll right click and choose
set root bone on selected solver.
And what that will do now is it will fill in the full body IK solver here so it's no longer
grayed out, which just means that it's active and its settings are set up correctly.
So if we were to select a couple of these goals here, these IK goals, you can see that
we can instantly move them and the pose of our character changes to compensate for that.
So one way to quickly test this and see how this looks on an animation would be to just
double click one of these animations in the asset browser here and shift our IK goals around
and see how that affects our character.
And you can see that really, really quickly, we actually have an animation playing our
character and we can adjust the pose of it in quite a basic way with just a few IK
goals, a full body solver and just making sure we set the root for that full body solver.
If I quickly set up an individual limb IK here just to compare that with the full body
IK solver, you'll see that it's really nice to use the full body IK solver because you
get all the extra little bit of nuanced movement.
So if I come up to add new solver, choose limb IK, I'll just do this with the back left
foot for example.
With that limb IK selected, I'll right click and connect that goal to the selected solver.
This is just another way to set things up.
And the top of that chain is going to be the thigh here.
So with that limb IK selected, if I right click set root bone on selected solver and
I just deactivate the full body solver for now.
When I select this rear left foot goal, you can see that we're affecting that entire chain
from the tip of the toe to the hip.
We're not getting any movement from the full body IK.
So if I turn that off and turn the full body IK back on, you can see that instantly everything
looks a lot nicer because we do get that extra movement from the whole body.
And that's really how quick it is to set up the IK rig asset.
Now a great advantage of this setting it up with the full body solver is that you end
up with that full range of motion and have the whole body reacting to each of the IK
goals or effectors.
Comparing that to like an individual limb chain where each of the root bones would sort
of be locked down to their initial positions in the animation.
Now the main sort of disadvantage of this is that you can't really use this within a
sequencer for any animation purposes.
It is designed for use inside an animation blueprint where you can adjust the pose on
the fly based on where you want these IK goals to be.
And here's an example of what that logic might look like.
So we have the animation playing on our character here where mannequin is pressing a button.
We then insert an IK rig node that references our IK rig asset that we've created and essentially
feed in a positional update to the goals position and in this case it's for the right hand to
adjust where the character is pressing a button before we reach our final output pose.